I get frequent shooting pains in Prometheus, my cancer, cancer stack two or probably four times daily. Each time I have this pain, I get between one to six sharp pains. Some have stopped me from moving.
You know why I'm having these pains. Usually when you get like stabbing shooting pains from the cancer, so pain has to do with either the tumor affecting a pain receptor, which so how you feel pain is you have pain receptors and you have two different types of pain receptors.
It could either be the cancer affecting that pain receptor, maybe emotion of your body that moves the cancer to affect that pain receptor or inflammation that's caused that's associated with the cancer that's affecting that pain receptor.
So it's just so getting those pains like that that come sharp pains and go have to do with the pain receptor.
The weight of Prometheus is heavy on my neck and he suggestions to minimize the load. Consider using one of those gator thing is that people, you know, years over their face when they're out fishing and stuff when it's cold morning.
That might give you some support that it's easy to stretch and pull on over that and it won't, you know, constrict so much to cause pain.
And then it's easy to throw in the wash machine and clean.
You could consider it a spandage and just cut it shorter so you can use it to pull up some sort of scarf I would think would help.
It is purged lots of fluid grayish pink and some blood strains the smell is very pungent so suggestions to make this more tolerable.
Well, you want it to be purged. That's what we want to be happening.
The pungent spell is dead cells.
The smaller lump on the neck is starting to impede my vocals again suggestions using your anti inflammatory nutrition and increasing the anti inflammatory nutrition is really the answer to that.
If you're using any over the counter into inflammatory medication like Advil or something like that, see if that makes a difference with the it's your vocal cords to because what Advil is is really an anti inflammatory.